welcome I'm David thorburn the director
of the MIT Communications Forum uh
normally we put the website's uh uh
homepage on the on the screen but I
won't uh uh we haven't done that today
so let me just mention that this is the
second of four forums we're sponsoring
this spring uh the third will be offered
on Thursday April 5th and its title is
adapting journalism to the web and it's
going to be a wide ranging discussion
about the ways in which the journalistic
principles and techniques of the print
era are migrating or not migrating onto
the web and whether that's a good or a
bad thing uh the final uh event will be
held at the end of uh the term in early
May on May 4th and it's titled
electronic literature and future books
and I hope many of you will attend that
uh uh event or pay attention to
that or check the check our website
where our events are archived in various
formats
um it's uh it it remains only for me to
welcome our speakers and to indicate to
those of you in the audience who are uh
new today that uh in some sense this
forum represents a kind of culmination
of a dayong set of conversations amongst
uh documentary filmmakers producers
media practitioners of various kinds and
Scholars and my hope is that the people
at the table will recall remember that
some members of the audience haven't
been there for your earlier discourse
distill your ideas uh we're very eager
to hear your most uh uh powerful and uh
uh compelling insights about this
Central subject uh our moderator today
is my friend and colleague William uio
the director of of the comparative media
studies program and the author of uh or
editor of a number of significant books
uh in including Mo uh most recently two
uh books that I think are edited books
media cultures and we we Europeans media
new collectivities and Europe I perhaps
should conclude here by saying that uh
in the uh uh as the comparative media
studies program has evolved especially
trying to recover from the departure of
the Visionary Henry Jenkins William uro
has been our load star and leader and
he's been doing I think quite remarkable
work in renovating and reconstituting
the comparative media studies program
one piece of evidence for that is this
remarkable forum and the activities that
preceded it in which so many media
practitioners began to talk about new
forms of documentary William David
thanks thanks for the kind words um and
thank you for coming tonight so as David
uh said we had a very exciting day uh
behind our back this is in a certain way
the culmination of the day uh and it
brought together as David said makers
and academics but it also brought
together together funders and folks from
festivals uh and the mix was an unusual
mix you don't often see more than two
sets of these players in one room at one
time what's going on right now in
documentary is nothing short of
transformational amazing um one of the
things I spoke about this morning in my
opening comments I tried to make the
case that what's happening today with
interactive on usually online
documentary um um sometimes location
based documentary sometimes trans media
documentary there's a lot of there's a
lot of form out there what's happening
today is to my mind very similar to what
happened almost 100 plus years ago with
the birth of the film industry
documentary which some of us think of as
the kind of lame cousin of the feature
film has in fact been a driver of
Technology it's been out and front from
the get-go something like 80% of the
films made uh between the startup film
film in 1895 and somewhere around 194
195 close to 80% of what was copyrighted
anyway was non-fiction now in our world
today that seems a little odd because we
would probably think that most of what's
out there is fictional if you look at
some of the first sound films um The
Jazz Singer is the one we me uh the one
we celebrate here in the US but in
Germany the first film the first sound
film was Melody der velt a documentary
in Russia it was vertov's enthusiasm so
documentary again was pushing the
envelope in terms of trying out new
technologies a lot of new color
technology was deployed with uh with
documentary a lot of the advances in 16
mimer uh and you know portable sound the
Advent of Cinema ver and direct Cinema
that transformation and production is
something that occurred in documentary
and not just that it you know it's not
just about new tools there was a
reimagination of the subject of the
relationship between the maker and the
subject that that those new tools uh
made possible and I guess where we are
today is at a real turning point in film
things like interactive film that that
the media lab the place we're in right
now pioneered in back in the
80s those techniques which were very
labor intensive very technology
intensive have become quite simple with
our new technologies and documentary as
ever is the first to pick that up and
drive it ahead so the folks here at this
table today all represent people who are
working in different aspects of these
new developments and I'll introduce them
in a second but the thing I really want
to emphasize and it was the the point of
today's discussion these new
developments are coming from unexpected
places it's not as though the
documentary Community has has thrown up
its hand an abandoned long form linear
documentary that's alive and well and
and will remain so rather it's that the
the radical or Progressive Fringe of the
documentary Community has picked up on
some of these two techniques they've
seen that they can do some remarkable
things with it it's not just the radical
Fringe it's organizations like the
national film Board of Canada uh that
have done have made a major commitment
in this sector a growing commitment and
they've seen the results in terms of
growing audience share in terms of being
able to reach beyond the broadcast
Market the national limits of a
broadcast market and reach an
international
market they've seen the ability of these
new forms to engage audiences not just
to let audiences watch these films and
maybe be inspired by them but actually
deepen themselves move around navigate
explore and engage in this work a lot of
other disciplines besides just uh
documentary makers have been involved
here and I just want to mention a few
people that are involved in interactive
art or New Media art have been Central
to these developments folks coming from
areas like cartography and especially
performative cartography where the
motion of the body in space it's not
just about Maps it's about performing
Maps those folks have been very
important game studies has been an area
that's yielded a lot Gamers often think
about narrative worlds worlds of
possibility that the user has to
negotiate and navigate um so a lot of
development here and what we're here to
you know naturally these developments
bring with them terrific opportunities
but also a lot of challenges challenges
like language do we call this
documentary or do we call it interactive
or collaborative or location do we use
some some prefix um I guess you could
answer that question by thinking about
video do we now do we call it all the
time digital video we've dropped the
digital we just call it video so
probably we're in a transition phase and
we'll keep those those prefixes but
they're not long to
stay um I think another set of questions
that we have are about Frameworks for
evaluation how do you tell a good one
from a bad one um that's very important
to funders it's very important to publ
because if they hit a few bad ones
they're probably not going to go back
for more so how can we build up a body
of criticism a set of critical
Frameworks to understand these new film
forms
um a lot of questions here and you know
questions that have implications for
funders what will they fund and what
won't they fund what category do things
fit in how do we show these things at
festivals something that's best seen on
a laptop where you the user can navigate
your way through it what do you do in a
public setting so these are some of the
questions that are percolating through
this space the main thing I want to get
across is that this is an incredibly
exciting moment this is a moment where
we're seeing the birth of a set of new
strategies new possibilities new forms
they have not yet been tamed there's not
yet an Orthodoxy or a set of rules or a
set of conventions for people to fall
back on there's nothing but possibility
and that's exciting that's a really
exciting moment uh it's exciting for
makers because they can do anything and
it and see if it works throw it at the
wall and see if it sticks it's exciting
for for for us uh the participants no
longer the audience but now we're
co-collaborators in these
projects um and it it's going to be
interesting to see what survives which
of these forms you know if there's the
usual process of reification and hard
wiring hard baking of some forms or if
we're actually going to see uh this this
this plurality increase um a lot of big
questions in terms of areas like ethics
who owns this material that's online if
you do a cut version are you the owner
or is the person who supplied the
footage the owner crowdsourcing say what
are the ethics of you know is there an
ethical issue there if you're making
money on the backs of what the the crowd
has produced a ton of issues on that
sector whole lot of issues having to do
with Legacy how will we preserve and
hold this moment how do we keep these
artifacts many of them are on relatively
fragile platforms platforms that are
here today and gone next year sometimes
they morph over sometimes they don't but
for historians you know are at least my
the historians of the future folks with
my line of work when they come back and
look at this moment what will be here to
look at will they see the various the
the the the huge array of steps that
we've taken so these and a bunch of
other questions are things that we'll
bring up um with the panel and the
format today will essentially be to um
to have a discussion uh with the
panelists um I'd like to introduce them
I'll introduce them as a group and then
go through one by one with a few
questions so we can talk about who they
are what their work is and then we'll
open it up uh for discussion so next to
me here is ingred uh cop who's uh the
New Media consultant for the Tribeca
Film Institute where she runs the TFI
New Media fund and that's really crucial
because that's the place that stimulates
that that makes possible a lot of this
new work it's a very new fund it's
started up this year
2011 and basically it's brokering Ford
fund money uh ingred is the kind of has
the critical accum and nose and
apparatus to to sort of Shepherd this
money into the hands of the right people
uh so it's a very she occupies a very
crucial bottleneck of possibility she
stands between the resources and those
out there with a lot of good ideas and
so a key decision maker a shaper of the
of the field next to ingred is Patricia
Zimmerman uh a fellow academic uh Patty
and I have been around the block a few
times and know each other for many years
she's professor in the department of
Cinema photography and media arts at
itha College co-directs the fingerlakes
environmental Film Festival author of
real families a social history of
amateur film uh mining the home movie
excavation in history and memories
states of emergency documentaries Wars
and democracy and Patty's what's really
intriguing about Patty's work is that
it's really focused on sectors that a
lot of other Scholars have ignored so
the home movie is a great example of a
of a kind of again a Grassroots approach
to Media something that Ordinary People
do doesn't necessarily get a lot of
public attention but it has profound
private meaning and um that's a crucial
sector especially today as we think
about collaborative and community- based
filmm so that's where some of her work
is
situated um next to Patty is Jerry
flahive who is a senior producer for the
national film Board of Canada a
remarkable organization one of the
world's few that continues to fund the
production of documentaries on a
relatively large scale I think Jerry you
said 14,000 documentaries to date that's
that's an incredible record and um he's
he's been the producer on a a number of
award-winning films water life and and
high-rise uh prominent among them and
and we'll talk about those um he's in
the position he's someone who's really
seen the transformation of this of of
the industry he's been there for the
Long Haul has seen this transformation
happen and he's seen it happen in an
organization that has been I think
really the world's leader if one had to
point to an organization that is doing
some of the most interesting work out
there it's it's the work that's coming
out of nfb for a bunch of distinctive
Canadian reasons that we will soon
discover and finally at the end of the
table is is sh Sharie frilo who's senior
programmer for the Sundance Film
Festival and curator of the New Frontier
section there and the New Frontier
section is where this kind of work
installation-based documentary uh
interactive documentary the new stuff
it's the repository of the new and and
shie is in that sense uh just as ingred
is sort of funneling the money shie is
shaping the taste out there and also
helping with the financial obviously
through that the financial side
exhibition is a really crucial sector
and that's something that as a festival
as someone who who organizes a festival
uh it's really a set of concerns that
she's faced with on a on a regular basis
sh you've been there for 11 years I
think so you've been
there we'll stop at
11 okay won't count
um and I should probably mentioned that
you're also an award-winning filmmaker
and and artist you've done installation
work as well as film work and been your
work's been seen in lots of Festival so
you've been on both sides of of of of
that
dance um and Char why don't I just um
well no maybe inred I'll start with you
because money is where a lot of this
begins
so um probably should cut
Canada we're only little we know that's
no let's do that that's not a bad idea
because that's a there's an
Institutional model that covers
everything you guys worry about
exhibition distribution funding um there
have been some interesting changes there
and that's probably the rock against
which or the metric against which all of
the things are measured and then we can
see how the the rest of us are trying to
scramble and catch up and make do
um so maybe just to start there it would
be
great I guess let's just start with what
do you do what's a what's a day in your
life what does a producer at nfb
do well um I I do what every other
producer does except I'm a civil servant
um
it is a uniquely Canadian institution I
think where we're we're not a funer
we're not a a broadcaster we're not an
Arts Council we're actually producers
and and Distributors and have been doing
that since 1939 so it's within the
Canadian context it's our mandate
actually hasn't changed in almost 75
years it's to interpret Canada to
Canadians and people in other nations so
I was saying to somebody about the
14,000 films and somebody was
questioning are there really 14,000
stories in Canada to be told haven't we
done them by now so um no there's we do
another hundred every year there's
apparently a few people we missed I I
think it's it's part of your citizenship
in Canada you get to be in an nfb film
you just show your passport you're
you're in um but it it's you know it's
it's an institution that's uh survived
and thrived uh and and part of that role
is um is pushing the boundaries it's
actually even though we're a government
Department we we report financially and
you know legally to the government but
we don't make government
films and there were other bodies like
that decades ago in Australia and India
and places like that other places that
seen the influence of John Gerson but
there's really nothing else left like it
so we have this unique Independence
editorial Independence and uh I think we
we do tell stories probably in a less
provincial way than we did 50 60 years
ago because there's a thriving film and
media industry in Canada so we don't
need to make the films about uh beaver
dams and wheat uh that maybe we did in
the there's nothing wrong with that um
that we did you know 50 years ago so
it's a it's a much broader brief and
they it may sound strange coming from uh
civil servant as I am but uh we're very
director driven it's the focus is very
much on point of view
documentaries um that that come from are
driven by a creative person um and the
move into interactive um which really
only started a few years ago it comes
from a creative place it really comes
from an embracing the creative
possibilities as the film board always
has done um not out of any imperative to
you know for distrib there there are
benefits from certainly from
distribution and and production cost
sides I wouldn't deny that as a producer
that I can produce something like uh one
of the high-rise projects we did out my
window which is 13 apartments in 13
cities all over the world uh cost about
$150,000 if we' done that as a film it
probably would have been
$750,000 but that's not why we did it
that way and and I think I'm most
excited by the creative possibilities
for interactivity I think I I absolutely
agree it's it's an incredibly exciting
time and I fear a little bit that there
is a a barrier for documentary
filmmakers who are fearing to make the
leap um and so the the field is going to
be filled up with people who you know
and this could be seen as a kind of a
threat in a way um who are not
filmmakers um and probably aren't even
necessarily thinking of themselves as
making do documentaries if you're doing
a data visualization project or a
documentary app is that a is that a
documentary so um I think our Legacy of
of having done as much work as we have
over that many years probably gives us a
certain cultural license to do the
things that we do there's deep respect
amongst the Canadian public for it so I
I totally understand it's not a model
that you know just why don't other
countries do this uh Canada was you know
is a big place with a very small number
of people in
1939 when it started so there were
historical Roots Norway Norway may be
thinking about it right um but you know
you you make an interesting point I just
want to follow so John greerson starts
this operation off and and he's very
much someone with the sense of both the
authorial vision the director's vision
and at the same time a notion of a a
kind of commitment but this new turn
towards interactivity in certain ways
can be seen at least the fear of some
traditional filmmakers is that this is
exactly taking away some of their contr
you're giving the audience a choice in
some cases to look at this or to look at
that to navigate this way or that way so
how does that align with because you
said there's this very strong commitment
to the director yeah do this does this
rub against that no I I don't think so I
mean I think I think giving the audience
that CH again as you said um I mean
we're spending a very large percentage
of our production dollars on interactive
it's about 25% so I there probably
aren't very many institutions in the
world spending but that means we're
spending 75% still on linear films so
you know we're not fearing that that
pure director vision of a linear
experience that the audience sits down
and watches is is going to go away as as
you said but I I don't think giving the
audience uh the users some greater role
to engage in how they want it the story
to unfold takes that away I still
absolutely believe that and I work with
an extraordinary filmmaker Katarina
sizzik behind the high-rise project
there you know as much as there's talked
about crowdsourcing and uh you know
opening up uh portals for content ENT
and user gen and all of that stuff I
don't think it works unless there's a
Creative Vision behind that it maybe
isn't one person but it it's it's
perhaps several people and I think there
has to be a strong creative concept
there and so there's still uh there are
degrees of collaboration you know and in
our project highrise which is four years
um there are some projects that are more
collaborative than others and and so cat
is still there's still a authorial voice
there there's still a sensibility that
that drives that and so I don't think
it's it's just it's trying something out
uh that's it's a little bit different
and and I don't think it's anything to
fear so one of the one of the
interesting things that happening is
that at these forms as I've already
suggested uh often are are seen on
computers and people navigate their way
through it and that doesn't align very
well with the needs of sort of Cinemas
you know the old style Cinema where you
have a mass audience a collective and
there's I guess a trade-off so you're
trading off the experience of being with
a mass audience for the the freedom to
kind of go where you want to go and
navigate I imagine there's also some
interesting data Trails Left Behind are
you are you able to better understand
your audiences and what their
experiences are like where those
audiences even are on the planet and how
does that align with the national film
boards remit I imagine it's it's the
national film Board of Canada for a
reason so what happens with things that
happen outside the border is that an
issue well it's it's shocking to
discover that people outside of Canada
are interested in Canadian stories i'
I've uh reached this point in my life
the Canadians generally feel no one else
would be interested in anything Canadian
um but uh the shocking news is that the
interactive work reaches audiences all
over the world um on a very very
Canadian subjects and I think that
that's opened our eyes to um if work is
good and it has a universal quality to
it I mean this may seem obvious uh to
perhaps American Producers whose work is
seen all over the world but with
documentary films you often don't know
you know our films are sometimes sold uh
around the world to broadcasters who go
to festivals and we kind of don't really
know who's seeing them in any
quantitative way with interactive work
there's a stream of data you see how
long people stay you see uh you know we
had a project one of our highrise
projects within two weeks of people from
180 countries that come to it wow and
that's we have no marketing we have no
massive marketing campaigns to do this
um so I think people are interested
again the shocking news is they're
interested in good work and and I think
audiences are actually
ahead of us often you know I your point
about these prefaces of you know it's an
interactive documentary I think it
probably will seem as quaint as saying
something is a VHS documentary you know
in a few years they're just there they
people are open to things and and the in
the web environment that they might not
be open to in a in a public environment
or coming into a theater and so I think
it's a very fluid exchange and we're you
know the the maybe troubling thing that
is a creative challenge that we learn is
people don't stay very long you know I
mean I think all of us know our own
habits on the web but you know when we
started some interactive work as a
producer of films that are sometimes
feature length to be told oh you know
seven minutes that's that's as long as
people will stick around um is is is
troubling but uh and it may influence
whether work interactive work is made in
a more modular way so people can almost
take pieces of it but what we did find
is there's often a very high return rate
so people are coming back you can track
that same user has come back uh a number
of times and so um I think the the
creative implications of that of
responding to that kind of experience
data is it's just too early like this is
we're talking a couple of years here
since we've we've been doing this and
anybody's been doing it in a way so one
last question and I hope it's not
impolitic to ask this of a civil servant
but there are a lot of ways to try to
understand this you you folks have
embraced interact interactive
documentary or documentary this new
documentary with a Vigor that is
unmatched uh maybe the French have
actually done the French and Australians
are actually doing are doing some good
work as well um and AR for a different
set of reasons and I guess I'm wondering
is this a matter of
um just having the wit to take quick
advantage of technological affordance is
this a budgetary issue could this be a
political issue I know your government
is with you know in in in step with the
rest of the western world has moved a
bit to the right um culture is is often
the first thing targeted is innovation
part of an argument to to keep the the
national film board strong or do you see
any of those as as um um I I mean
blessedly we're we're quite removed from
politics in that sense and and I think I
think what we've done is is been
applauded by the government but um you
know I mean I guess there was just as
much of a risk that we would fail that
these would be seen as these sort of
laboratory experiments these weird
interactive documentaries that didn't
quite work um and and so I you know
there wasn't necessarily a guaranteed
payoff and and if if that was if that
had been the reason which it wasn't um
financially I mean there you know it's a
government agency and and you know Cuts
Cuts will come probably in the future
but um yeah that's not really that's not
really driving it I think it is it's it
came from the top it came from Tom prut
who's the head of the film boards in
around
2006 saying um we should really embrace
the web as a platform to make things and
a project I did with cat sizzik just
before highrise called filmmaker and
residence um which was one of the first
long form interactive documentaries we
did in 2006 we started work on that
project in 2004 there was no Facebook no
YouTube no Twitter so even saying we're
making films to show on the web would
have been a somewhat radical uh notion
but the idea of a web site as as a as
the creative production uh was kind of
inexplicable you know and 2005 that that
was it's like websites are there to
Market films that's that's their sole
purpose isn't that right um so it's very
very recent and I think it wasn't it you
know we weren't putting 25% of our
production dollars in day one you know
there were some small experiments and
and some small things and even something
like waterlife which has had one and a
half million unique visitors from all
over the world cost
$55,000 so it's not uh it's not a
million dollar uh Gamble and I just just
to recall one the things you said
earlier today because it's a striking
it's a it's a real endorsement I think
of the way the the national film board
works you said you had you were funded
you you put in a proposal to fund a
project to do four years of research and
you weren't sure what kind of artifacts
were going to come out that's right
that's the that's high-rise that's the
project we're doing right now um which
is a high-rise is a four-year many media
project looking at how we live
vertically around the world and there we
have strong roots and strong
storytelling in Toronto but we've done
uh part of the project has been in other
cities around the world and so it came
out of that filmmaker residence project
we did in a hospital where we kind of
explored collaboration working with
people rather than making a single film
about a subject is to spend a lot of
time around a subject around original
research and with communities and see
what emerges and so by the time we got
to the table with highrise idea in
around 2008 I think we were trusted
sufficiently uh in that context and I'm
you know privileged to work in a place
that gives us that trust where we said
we've done deep research this is a this
is a good creative concept U more than
half the people in the world are living
in cities billions of us live in
apartment buildings there's something
there uh but we want it to be platform
agnostic we don't know what we're going
to make and they said yes so we've made
a bunch of things so far and we've done
installations and live performances and
uh some short films and mostly uh mostly
it's all up at highrise
nfb.com web based work but we've been
approached by a publisher to do a book
and we've been approached by uh radio
producers to do radio and somebody from
a theater company wants to adapt some of
the work for theater so it's a
laboratory within a laboratory and U I
think we still have the responsibility
to do good work that reaches audiences
that doesn't go away wow great so ingr
I'm gonna turn to you because we're
talking about so this is the way the
state does it and an En the enlightened
State the um social
socialist socialist Paradise so um here
in the land of the Greenback um things
work a little bit differently right so
you run a new media fund yeah for a film
festival no I so yeah it's but it is
confusing so um the Tribeca Film
Institute which is where I am uh working
on this fund is the nonprofit bit of
Tribeca which is this like overarching
thing which includes the Tribeca Film
Festival which is so we're we're part of
the same family but we're we're slightly
separate we're in separate offices um
and so the Tribeca Film Institute is the
is the nonprofit Institute where we
support filmmakers with a varie of
Grants across both narrative and
documentaries and um and last year we
launched this TFI New Media fund to
start exploring um interactive
documentary funding uh so I mean I you
know I've been full of uh both
admiration and and Green Envy for uh all
the work that the nfb have been doing in
this space for for as long as they've
been doing this interactive stuff and um
you know and obviously we have a very
very different model because ours as a
straight fund um we fund four to eight
projects a year um in the range the
funds range between 50 and 100,000 and
it's a straight fund so we we don't hold
any rights and uh we don't do any
production on our end um although I we
can talk about this later we have ended
up becoming more involved with the
projects in this fund than in other
funds for lots of reasons because they
need the support so we're trying to
build that in now in traditional funding
either for a feature or for a
documentary there are a lot of sort of
standard things you can look at you can
look at the the CV of the filmmaker you
can see what they made before you know
what a treatment looks like you know
what a film is supposed to sort of look
like how does that work with these with
these objects right well I think you
know one of the things that I think was
really interesting when we were setting
up this fund is although I do agree that
a lot of innovation comes from within
documentary I do think that in this
sphere um the last place I was looking
for Innovation was generally the
documentary Community um I mean outside
of the nfb and Arte there really is
hardly there was and is hardly any work
being done in this space and and like
Jerry I you know I've been really
concerned with look looking at what
happened with newspapers online and how
you know when the the times and other
sort of big prints um papers they were
you know very nervous about getting
online and so you had like Yahoo news
and the hington post rushing into to
fill that space and for me I was always
really concerned that that was going to
happen with with the documentary space
because a lot of the most creative and
clever and you know truly interactive
experiments I was seeing online were
coming from the brand space um because
obviously advertisers are desperate to
sell things to audiences who are fleeing
from the 30C spot on television and so
you know there was so much Innovation
there and so actually you know a lot of
the inspiration I was getting was
actually outside of documentary and I
was thinking what if we could bring the
stories that we really care about that
are not selling things that are actually
about creating the culture that is
important to us to the space
um and what if we bring like all these
amazing documentary filmmakers and this
incredible technology together um so
that we can innovate in the space as
well and it's not just left to selling
things that was really for me a really
key part of of setting this fund up and
let me just so that's that suggests that
your role is something of a curator that
you're someone who has a sense of where
you'd like the field to go what you
think is what's interesting and what is
less interesting and you can in a
certain sense use use the use the fund
as a way to to stimulate um a vision as
as a way to make that happen yeah I mean
you're right and I'm I'm also very
nervous of that actually um because you
know I think I mean I think one of the
things that I've brought to this which
um is great is that I'm really
interested in technology generally and
I'm you know I I think it's it's very
interesting to for me to sort of have a
sort of overarching sense of where
things are going and how people are
using technology and you know what's
happening in in branding and interactive
journalism across the field to me that's
very very interesting and the sort of
digital ecosystem is all very relevant
to this field
um but I also you know it's definitely
Through My Lens so one of the things
that worries me a little bit and I don't
know if this is something that comes up
at the nfb but I I would hate for this
fund and my vision to be this gatekeeper
that sort of decides because I've tried
to be really UN non-prescriptive in in
what this interactive stuff looks like
um because I really do want it to be
open I want there to be space for open
source projects and iPad apps and you
know um total trans media experiences
whatever is necessary for that project
um but I'm also so you know I I'm
definitely bringing my background to
this work and um and I I do I am
concerned that if there isn't more more
if there aren't more voices to sort of
balance me and to balance this fund that
it it may become like sort of my vision
of what this should be which I is
necessarily going to be narrow well I'm
grateful actually you're at the helm in
this case because you have a very broad
Vision as far as I can tell and as you
just said and it sounds like the the the
the controlling part of your vision is
really probably more about quality it's
not about what the form is per se as
much as is it going to be a good example
of whatever it tries to be how do you
judge that because it strikes me look I
mean I've read a lot about this on the
web and I'm not I'm not really bowled
over by the level of criticism of of a
of a critical culture I don't mean in a
negative sense but just in an analytic
or evaluative sense I don't see a lot of
I mean there's there's a lot that's out
there but there aren't reliable voices
or many reliable voices that I turn to
which one knows I mean you know who to
turn to in or at least you know how to
assess opinions in the world of linear
documentary or feature film so how do
you how do you make those calls where do
you how do you get in how do you inform
yourself well it's it's I think it's two
things I mean there's there's the sort
of lack of critical voices and then
there's also you know having to write
guidelines for a fund which is very
specific like you know about this fund
this is what we're looking for points
one two 3 four um and in order to do
that I mean I I had to just make
decisions and what I tried to do is just
keep it really open so I Bas I basically
said um tell us what you're doing tell
us why you're doing it and we we'll
we'll know when we see it I mean that
really is I mean I I think this will
change but right now that that is the
guidelines um in terms of critical
discourse I agree and you know it would
be great if there was more discussion
around this work the one thing that I am
a bit nervous about though and I I
mentioned this before um when I was
talking during the day today um is that
we need to be able to fail in the space
I think it's so important that there's a
space for experimentation and failure um
good failure and um and one of the
things that I do get a bit worried about
is and and maybe it's because I'm so
interested in the technology as well so
I'm always looking at like how things
are built and the technology they used
and is it open source and you know what
happened with the audience and but but
one of the things that does worry me is
some of these projects may seem a little
bit gimmicky sometimes and maybe they
don't have the um the sort of Slam Dunk
uh effect of a you know of a great
linear documentary that goes to all the
big festivals and wins Awards and you
know it's like you know you know all the
things that it needs to hit in order to
be a respected documentary we don't
really have that in the space so I'm I
also feel a bit protective of these sort
of little experiments growing up and
that you know we don't want to like slam
them down before they've had a chance to
really find their space and one of the
things that I think is really important
with the fund is that we we are allowed
to be part of that experimentation
process rather than kind of come out the
gate saying okay we've solved this um
because I knew that was never going to
be the case oh terrific so you're in
year one still in year one no year two
is well we we've we've we just closed
sub missions for year two so yeah so
we're sophomores now so you're at the
start of this and and and besides more
money to work with what's your fantasy
about where this could go if you were to
think over the next decade where could
this where could this fund go and maybe
where could the field go as you as you
look at it I mean I definitely look at
in with within the field um because I
think you know One Fund I I mean I'm
sure a lot of you know this but you know
generally documentary funds tend to be
10,000 here 40,000 here maybe 50 or
100,000 if you're really lucky and you
know I'm under no I I know that that
it's a little piece of what you need to
get your project made and in the US what
we tend to do is you know we sort of
become sort of story entrepreneurs and
we piece together the funding as we go
until we manage to make something um and
uh you know so I I think it definitely
has to be I look at it as part of the
field as a whole One Fund is not going
to be enough um but one of the things
that I am really really really keen on
building is more research and
development and so um this is something
something else that I brought up earlier
I I want more rapid prototyping I want
more experimentation where we can sort
of fail fast and better and learn from
our failures or good failures I don't
know if there's a word for good failures
um so that there's really like a you
know like there is in the sort of
startup entrepreneurial Community the
sense of like you can try things see
what works see what doesn't work and
move on um so that there's just more
work being produced and more
experimentation happening and one of the
things specifically with a fund that I
really want to do is because we're not
producers so we don't really have a sort
of day-to-day hand in the projects but
one of the things we are doing is
getting the the fundes the grantees to
collaborate with each other so that
they're sharing and and I I facilitate
that and then we we were're also doing a
lab at the festival and what I'd like to
do is really sort of build more sort of
lab support and mentorship on in every
stage of the process so that these
projects have get the help that they
need in terms of connecting with coders
and developers and designers which is
really key thinking about user
experience thinking about all the things
you need to think about now to make work
in the space um so being able to build
that into the fund I think would be
really amazing that's terrific that's
terrific and it makes me think of two
comments that came up in today's session
that I just want to mention one was with
regard to a project like highrise um
where you know we we mentioned the
luxury of four years of research and
let's see what happens um a lot of that
research was carried out with
universities and that strikes me as a
very fertile ground I mean there are a
lot of universities there's a lot of
great research that Finds Its way into
poorly Publications and uh That Could
Have Much Greater impact in the hands of
people that do some you know creative
interpretation of uh actuality um I
think it challenges us as documentary
filmmakers to try to be running
alongside academic research academics
who are doing bleeding edge research
rather than us you know kind of waiting
till it's finished right you know is is
that's an interesting but scary space
sometimes to be end um you know we've
done documentaries where there's there
isn't a body of work to support I've
actually had films rejected uh at
proposal stage because there wasn't a
body of academic work to sort of support
it and we had to kind a push back so
that's a really interesting place to be
you know I think that is a totally
untapped resource is that relationship
whether it's linear docs or interactive
between Doc filmmakers and uh
academics well so I was just going to
say so that so one of the things we've
just set up in terms you know in terms
of building this this collaborative
Community um of practitioners and
thinkers is we've we've set up this
project called living docks with the
center for social media at the American
University with Milla who do Firefox
with itvs and with bayac in the in the
Bay Area uh where we can sort of share
information and code um and resources
around um open- Source documentary
practice and I'd love to see more of
that you know more kind of um more kind
of sharing of resources across
disciplines because one of I I call I've
started to call Convergence smush cuz I
keep thinking about it like where we're
all smushing you know um media are
shushing but also Industries are
shushing and silos are breaking down so
for me it's it's like where do we
innovate in Theo and that's how I always
that is my incredibly academic way of
thinking about the
space great and it's a space well we
thrive in smoosh here so we need to we
need to talk um the other thing I just
want to mention because it I'm thinking
of it now but it it also came up today
which was the the ways and 18 days in
Egypt is a great example of this where
you can actually learn from good
experiences are bad as people interact
with these documentaries online you can
actually respond and tweak your tweak
your your material to work better with
the audience to sort of see what's not
working what could be enhanced and that
that interactivity between the maker and
the and the user is actually another
great affordance and uh so terrific so
sh let's turn over to the to the world
of um exhibition um so to in order to
sort of put festivals into perspective
and the challenges of showing
interactive documentaries and how how
how users are going to engage with them
what can you tell us about your years at
the uh at Sundance and um what can you
tell us what have you learned what have
you in terms of how to exhibit this
material in terms of how users work with
it well I've been uh my original and
remaining continuing role is to select
films for the festival and I I select
feature documentaries feature films um
and well I guess the I suppose what I've
learned
is at Sundance we're a discovery
Festival we we follow the artist and uh
New Frontier has been set up uh to allow
us to continue to do that so it's a it's
very much within the Continuum of our
mission and our interest as a discovery
Festival uh in terms of exhibiting and
making that work accessible to audiences
is a is a little bit of a different
thing uh in terms of you know just sort
of when people are ready for what it
it's it's often the case and books have
been read written about this that the
artists are are are ahead of even the
mathematicians and scientists in terms
of their paradigms and how they think
about things and they certainly are
ahead of the audiences uh but I think
nowadays the audience are actually
starting to catch up and the industries
are starting to catch up out of
necessity I think particularly in the
film
industry the um it's you know with new
frontier Frontier was a section of the
festival that's that's always been uh
had an eye trained on Innovation
experimentation expanding the envelope
of how to tell stories so it was a
natural place uh to develop um a
showcase for for new new forms of of
Storytelling uh so we we Reiner the
frontier as new
frontier and uh sort of thought very
carefully about how to build uh a space
in really really what what we what we
realize is that we had to build a
culture within the festival culture for
this work it's not so much you know what
corner what building we're going to show
this work but actually how do we how do
we how do we um nurture a culture for
this work and nure a culture for
curiosity uh for a different kind a new
kind of Storytelling so the way that we
built this platform uh was to think
about uh you know work that that we're
we're seeing in the art world and in New
Media that speaks a film festival
language that speaks a cinematic
language that's accessible so that when
people come in and see the work they
don't feel like they've read the wrong
books and walk out you know in in the
midst of a very very busy Festival
environment that's really important uh
uh the other part of it is um you know
the the space has to be comfortable uh
the space has to be social it has to
resonate with not only the festival
environment but also so with what this
work is intending to resonate uh uh uh
just generally in our lives our daily
life is a an immersive media
installation and so this work you know
this is a point of accessibility this
work speaks to that that that that
fact uh so we um you know we build
something that is not not really a a
white box or a black box but more of a
social Lounge environment uh with with
SE ta lighting and and couches and
lounges and uh and and galleries that
kind of um spin off off of the lounges
and there's also a micro Cinema there
that sort of the heartbeat of the venue
that uh we we present performances that
engage with a moving image as well as uh
panels and forums and presentations uh
and and where where companies can
actually present new technologies to
filmmakers who want to get their hands
on that so it's really kind of building
a culture within a culture a festival
inside of a festival
um and and and figuring out how to
integrate this exhibition into the
festival at large so I've been to enough
festivals to know that there are many
audiences many different audiences the
people that just go to the you know what
are going to be the award winners and
the the the folks who go to the fringy
stuff how are how's how are you seeing
that audience grow are you seeing
newcomers gravitate to that Jerry
mentioned earlier the issue of you know
if if if our traditional filmmakers are
not going to make the move to the
interactive stuff it's just going to be
the FKS coming from in a certain way
from outside uh who are attracted to the
technology and the interactivity but
maybe don't have the same storytelling
chops as as that other generation that's
what are you finding with audiences is
this a young is there a profile a
demographic profile are you seeing this
as a growing and new kind of audience
that's being attractive to Sundance how
would you characterize that well in the
beginning when we started in 2007 our
very first edition of New Frontier it
was the youngest audience I think I'd
seen at the festival I mean babies even
sometimes because we were projecting
work on the on the ground you know and
and there were children on the ground
and you know projecting on the walls of
spaces and so it was very playful space
and a lot of young people um really
engaged with that on that level we also
aggressively went for a young audience
as well we developed a curriculum to be
able to um to bring high school and
college students into the space because
I just had we had an instinct that um
you know that audience would probably
understand and and be open to what we
were trying to do in the beginning
stages um uh o over time our press
Department actually started to use a
curriculum to talk to the Press Corps so
that to help them talk about the work um
to develop you know some kind of
critical uh perspective and a way of
talking about it because in the
beginning actually they they talked
about it as art at Sundance and had to
stop that right now it's not hard at
Sundance this is expanding Cinema
culture that's what we're doing here I
think um
in 2009 when the independent film World
kind of broke in half uh when you know
when when the recession really hit it
hit our industry especially hard and
especially early um we started to see a
u an expansion of the audience for New
Frontier I think the when the studios
sort of lost their independent um
shingles and a lot of the companies went
out of business a lot of the executives
still came to Sundance out of maybe love
for it out of Community out of Sher
determination you know um and uh you
know so there was a there was a there
was a love there uh that I and and and
people were looking for answers for you
know what to do with um how do we move
forward when we don't have these
traditional ways of funding films and
exhibiting films anymore and so so
projects like Joseph Gordon Levitz hit
record got a lot of attention you know
that year this is a you know a a
well-known American actor uh has been in
Hollywood movies and done a number of
independent films and he started a a a
production company called hit record
where he would crowd Source films and he
would be the creative director that that
um that spoke to a new way a new
paradigm that could be crawling up from
the cracks of the broken um stuff that
that was the detrius let's say of uh of
the old what of the old world so um
we're starting to get now more diverse
audience coming to it and um and and and
also a more literate audience too I
think the first couple of years the
Press Corps kind of you know we set up a
brunch um and they talk to each other
and the artists are over here and just
scared of the
artists and um but but and eventually
around 2009 2010 we couldn't pull them
off the artists something about maybe
just their meat and potatoes how they
saw the movies you know I started watch
watching movies online most of the
people that I know are assuming movies
so there's a there's a there's this
notion that movies equals digital
technology equals what's going on at New
Frontier what's what's going on over
there so I think that there's there's
been a maturation in the audience that
that I've seen coming through it's been
interesting so I have a distribution
question and it and it comes from my
understanding when I think of festivals
I think of them as similar actually to
the kind of educational thing we do at
universities which is to try to
translate not to use the craziest case
but to use to sort of figure out where
people are and how to how to help them
move into where things are going and to
try to help them understand it to try to
contextualize it to try to excite them
and stimulate them but not freak them
out uh and over overwhelm them and um
and that sounds a bit like what you're
doing with these with your choices of of
of what's going to be at uh at New
Frontier um another function of
festivals that's different from what we
do at universities is that when
something's endorsed by a festival wins
an award is uh nominated but even shown
it has some credibility in terms of
distribution Distributors are it's been
vetted in a sense and um how is that
working in this sector I mean we kind of
know how it works in the in the in the
sector of feature films and and linear
traditional documentaries but in this
sector does that same logic hold are
there Distributors for this material or
is this stuff people just put up online
and the only Revenue model is getting
money from a found foundation and uh
from Tribeca and uh well you know make
no mistake I'm definitely trying to
freak my audiences out um but I'm but
I'm trying to do it before they know it
they're freaked out it's too late and
they're already freaked out and they're
like oh wow it's actually not so bad
it's kind of cool um you know in terms
of the distribution I mean with the work
that that that we tend to show at New
Frontier a lot of it is Bound for the
art World a lot of it finds a home in
museums
in art centers um you know some some
some work uh you know operates within
the within the space of the internet you
know digital space um but uh you know
distribution as you talk about it sounds
like you're talking about films and um
you know and and basically that that
distribution model is widgets you know
kind of going around and just recently
has it been streamed you know a stream
of electrons into your into your into
your computer
um I'm not sure if if the if the
marketplace is headed in that direction
for this work and and I say that with
some
Joy because I I think that the
marketplace and and Patricia probably
will um uh agree with this that the the
mark that that linear um narrative
actually is historically derivative it's
it was when when when Cinema first came
about we actually had news reels it
wasn't it was it was the exhibitor that
was the curator of the media and it
wasn't until you know there was an
effort to sell the work that we had
established a linear narrative so this
is actually this kind of work is kind of
going back to the origins of Cinema and
how and and how it existed and um you
know I would like to see a new model um
I have no idea what it would look like I
only have ideas of how I would I I as an
exhibition person you know interest in
exhibition and and having the experience
of being at Sundance and and and and
being with Sundance who has a history of
taking one genra that didn't have a
market at all and actually had built an
industry around it through cooperation
with various players um and um you know
really kind of built an industry where
there was none that there might be some
lessons there uh for this new genre uh
in terms of the key role that exhibition
plays to create an audience for um a
kind of media that otherwise or had
previously been uh overlooked or unknown
and mus and music is probably another
really interesting model to look at the
distribution model was just fine and
dandy in the days of artifacts but now
that we have you know online the ability
to directly access things online then
the performance space actually becomes
far more important as a driver of a
former of taste absolutely you know in
fact there was a a film uh film that I
that I showed it was a piece that I
showed at New Frontier called utopian
for movements by uh the documentarian
Sam green uh and and Dave Surf and he
actually looked consciously to the music
Paradigm because he knew this was
heading to his way uh to make a a
documentary that was a live performance
using PowerPoint point you know using
digital technology and uh and it was
just a and it's a beautiful piece you
know just the Resonance of like a live
performance and the fallibility talking
about Utopia was just really just a
beautiful match and uh you know he he's
he's he's been traveling ever since
2010 with this piece just like uh a band
would um so it's it's it's a new
business model for a a tried and- true
Oscar nominated filmmaker that's
terrific thanks so Patty we're going to
turn to you for a few questions and so
you're a historian of the Forum you've
worked on really in the Spectrum the
whole spectrum of of documentary as I
said home movies have we seen this
before are there aspects of this
development that you think are different
from what's come before it can we expect
the same patterns of containment within
a couple you know innovate radical
Innovation and then some pretty frantic
attempts to contain it or is there
something different here and we've
already just suggested that distribution
might be a a misnomer in this sector
that there might be other ways to think
of that what's your
sense well I'm going to speak as a
historian a theorist and also as a
programmer so I I think in this moment
there's a huge tendency in certain
sectors to say everything is new and
every problem we saw in documentary will
be resolved through interactivity
through interface whatever so if there's
a problem of we didn't have access to
tools now we have access ACC to tools
right if there's a problem of only uh
people who are heavily resourced can
make long form feature documentaries and
conflict zones generally white and male
from First World countries now we have
user generated media so I think there's
that's one moment we're in of just utter
utopianism of uh there's this incredible
democratization of tools ideas Etc okay
so I think that we always see that in
documentary I think you have to be
hopeful to be in this field okay it's a
tough field to be in uh you know so I
think that's a continuity on the other
hand I think that there is I think if
you as you've pointed out bill there's
always um issues of technology that are
always challenging makers uh
Technologies are not static as anyone
here at MIT knows every technology in
the history of media
uh is made every technology has been
modded and changed every technology has
been taken apart and reversed engineered
in different contexts as it goes around
the world so I think in some ways the
moment we're in is a moment we've been
in since
1892 right
um what do I think has changed um what I
think has changed as as people were
talking I thought I i' you know make a
little list and one thing I think we're
moving from is from the one to the many
right like the one film right I'll just
you know I call them the big white whale
films right big featurelength
documentaries there's still a place for
them I you know I will totally agree
that there is but now we're moving to a
more variegated uh Eco system with a
multiplication of forms even a
featurelength film may have a
multiplication of forms and iterations
so you know back in the day let's just
say when I was in grad school in the 70s
we had fixity right I am going to watch
this film Analyze This film put it in a
historical context now we have fluidity
now we have I just give you my list and
I'm sure people here can add to it
besides long form feature films we have
search engine documentaries right just
based on search engines we have web
archives hurricane Han Katrina archive
uh is a one I particularly admire uh we
have user generated stories like 18
Egypt we have live streaming games and
gamification installation with every
kind of Technology imaginable uh
performances that mix analog and digital
we have remix we have cartographies and
mapping projects we have live music
projects we have music that uses media
behind it we have live music that uses
projections we have multimedia we have
cell phone Symphonies we have music
triggered by technology technology
triggering images guitarists triggering
a remix algorithm we have applications
we have aife we have locative media
projects investigating our FID we have
projections on every kind of surface in
every kind of space imaginable uh we
have takeovers of screens where
universities put their you know go to
this talk and then we have artist
interface projects we have sensor
projects we have args alternate reality
gaming we have phones we have robotics
uh you know the I'm I'm sure this isn't
an exhaustive list but what does this
all have in common I just wanted to say
this as we talk about like you know this
uh you know what I would call the
funeral for the long form traditional
documentary right you know here we are
at the funeral for it that actually it's
just part of this
really um uh kind of jungle beautiful
ecosystem of so many multiplying forms
so how could you put a summary on that I
think we're moving from fixed images in
documentary to thinking about movable
endlessly mutating always permeable
fluid interfaces and and that's kind of
what I see and to me it's a really
exciting moment uh I think it's a moment
of incredible confusion uh as ingr said
earlier incredible anxiety uh incredible
hope and incredible Despair and as one
of my mentors uh the historian Eric
barno said uh in the history of media
there's never been a new technology met
without equal parts of Hope and despair
right and I think it's you know it's
extremely dialectical moment uh and that
makes it really really really really
exciting um so so let me ask as a as
someone you know in the trade in the
academic trade um In The Biz In The Biz
is a big issue and and as a media
scholar part of your remit at University
is to is to try
to improve the literacy levels of our of
our students who who consume quite a bit
of media uh or at least it's a topic
that comes up do you think a new set or
a new set of skills required to take on
this this plethora of new developments
that you talked about or are students
coming already our kids growing up well
armed and ready to take this on where do
you see the place for um for literacies
uh Lites in this you know I'm really
glad you asked that question I actually
made I'm a list maker a very German so I
I like sit here and make list um so uh
literacies uh here's what I think uh you
know I teach courses in what I call like
fixed old school film right film history
Show the movie you know here's the
context here's the history here's the
Aesthetics I also teach courses in
digital Theory and what's interesting to
me is I think everyone assumes the
millennial generation lives in
technology and knows more than we do
okay and what I have discovered is the
technology that they live in is
corporatized is
individuated is consumerist and is a
form you'll excuse me if I make a
religious uh moment here but it's to me
a kind of digital onanism right you know
you're you're kind of there alone doing
your thing so what I have discovered you
know in classes and also as a programmer
when I go around kind of prizz for new
forms of
documentary is I think most students do
not have a language to approach this new
work and probably I would say as most
Scholars like us don't have a language
because as Scholars we are trained to
have I'm going to lift this up an image
and it's there and you can analyze it so
what do you do when the thing starts
moving around and every time you look at
it it looks different and maybe you're
not even looking at an image you're
looking at an interface or maybe you're
looking at an algorithm or search engine
so I think we don't have a language for
it yet because I think Academia is
really old-fashioned and we want our
models based on fixity so uh what I find
is when I show these Works in classes or
when I go around and show them people
get really excited just to have someone
conjure up a space where you can argue
about about these works I I'll say one
other one other point I want to pick up
on the uh Indie band model um I I think
that these business models I get nervous
when I hear the word business but I
think they're important for artists and
I think the Indie band Indie music model
has been really powerful for so many
artists working in New Media and what I
see in this Paradigm is um don't
theorize accessor R and what I mean by
this is you'll see you know what I'm
talking about you'll see people who have
these projects right they're doing live
remix with the music live music all
these computers and you can buy a CD of
the music you can buy a CD of the mix
you can buy the app you can get the
T-shirt you can get the Hat you can get
the sticker and in fact at the form
today uh someone asked uh the people
from one of the projects well you have
that t-shirt on for your your project
but it's not on your website so I think
this this idea of um all of that that
has helped some people to monetize um
you know in my situation I've had a lot
of artists come to Ithaca College and
they make a lot of money selling these
things right um because it's sort of a a
country of people who
collect hats and t-shirts and and all
that so I I think it's a you know we're
we're in an odd odd moment
um in terms of odd meaning exciting
right because we don't really know what
we think about all of this and to me I
think the only things we're thinking
about are those that are Unthinkable
moments if that makes any sense in kind
of a Zen way right if it's confusing and
Unthinkable then it's worth thinking
about and I find myself when I'm showing
like those documentaries right the you
know the the flat on the wall starts and
finishes character conflict Zone guy
with a camera cry and the audience feel
moved to participate in the bigger World
outside the US movies I find I'm kind of
bored because I kind of know the
Paradigm but when I see things just to
give you an example of uh this is uh
this artist I really like China Tracy C
from China okay so the China Tracy
project she builds
Chinese hyper Urban cities in Second
Life but China Tracy is also a project
where it's like this fake city right
that has a website and has a mayor and
they have press conferences so it kind
of
moves and migrates between analog and
digital between being a performance
being second life I find myself really
interested in that why because it
perplexes me in the way I was trained to
think think as a documentary scholar
fantasy did not figure into documentary
but now but now it does and I made a
list of a bunch of projects like that
but I won't bore you with another
another list I'll say one one moment I
see I think that of his the history of
documentary I mean and partly this is so
embedded from political movements of the
70s has often been one of pushing out
right um here's an argument push out the
argument convince people right it's a
sort of can opener idea put the can
opener on the head crank it open pour in
whatever idea you have about whatever
conflict zone is in the world put it
back on walk out I am an Engaged citizen
of the Universe um so I think that kind
of push out strategy we still see in
some sectors but what's interested me
are works that are going in the opposite
direction I would call them Pullin
projects um projects that are a about
not being confrontational not taking a
can opener usually electric can opener
to someone's head but that are
infiltrations invitations inviting
people into a
conversation uh creating a convening I
mean there's so many projects like this
and I find this to be new right this is
no longer about um having so much
deductive argumentation I still think
there's a role for those words but I'm
really interested in these works that
kind of pull in um and I think a lot of
these works are not being put in
theaters but are being located in spaces
where we never put films in
documentaries clubs um um people
remixing on walls uh people doing uh
live
performances um out in space in other
words going to where people are rather
than bringing people in to where the
work is and I just think it's exci
exciting and you know I have to say I
got this idea not from projects in the
US I think we see projects like this in
Asia Africa Latin America where being in
public space and creating Civil Society
in small provisional Gatherings is
absolutely urgent in countries where
there have been genocide or
environmental degreg or no public sphere
I I can specify this later I but so my
summary is old school was push out you
know go build your audience and I think
the kind of new ways that I'm seeing
across all these different iterations is
more of a pull in I think it's a you
know gentler I know a lot of old you
know filmmakers in this other mode think
this stuff is is not political I don't
even know what that means anymore so can
I make one point on that one of the
things that I think that goes back to a
point I was making earlier though about
why I feel like we really need to be in
the space because you're I think you're
absolutely right about the pull in
versus push out but the people who are
really good at that are Brands um and I
think that also goes back to you know
this experience that a lot of I think
people have with technology I mean it's
called inbound marketing there's a term
for it and I think it's everywhere and
it's really pernicious um and you know
just even the way when you connect with
Facebook it sort of it drifts across the
internet and follows you where you go
and I mean I'm not you know I'm not a
conspiracy theorist about it I think
there's lots of things about it that are
fine actually it's kind of it is the way
we're living now but I it it does
concern me in terms of like where we are
in the space and I think that one of the
things that I'm really interested as
well with this is actually challenging
the technology a little bit I think what
Jonathan Harris is doing with Cowbird
where he actually doesn't have video is
really interesting it's like do we
always need to have video why why don't
we just have a big image and slow the
internet down or jarn Lan's point about
you know not dumbing ourselves down
because we think technology is so
amazing and actually sometimes we can
say well this is what we want to do and
humanize the technology I think that's
really important because the the the
pull in can be quite Insidious as well
as as well as very powerful or
insidiously powerful I
guess let's open this up for questions
so if you want to make your way over to
the mics
um where I was going to turn the convers
or do we have someone where I was going
to turn the conversation were actually
challenges and that's exactly what you
guys are talking about um there are a
lot of challenges that face us um any
others that we haven't addressed because
we've talked about quite quite a few so
far maybe I can engage Patty on
something that that you brought up that
that
and and you William about
literacy I thought a lot about this in
this last show in terms of how to you
know what was important to the film to
the film Community uh to to to talk
about to address and and underlying that
show is this notion uh and it has
something to do with the push in push
out is is is that film
itself is um changing roles it's no
longer
uh to be consumed it's actually becoming
part of our language how we speak to one
another other it's becoming part of a
certain kind of AR architecture a new
kind of architecture within the world we
live in so it's a it's a very different
role that it's playing um if you think
about you know how we build philosophies
and and and and and conversations it's
often in exchange of tiny bits of media
bits of stories um you know how we how
how histories are built you know Lin
hman Leon's work uh raw War which is a
is a documentary straight documentary
about um women the women art movement in
in America and how it's been overlooked
by historians and the interactive part
uh uh which is called raw War where uh
you can C she basically sets up a
platform to crowdsource that history uh
so thereby completely obliterating the
Paradigm of History making from a
curatorial one to to an inclusive one
you know this this is this is um the
role of the media is is one that is is
the glue between people and society as
opposed to the entertainment that that
you know or the message so I think I
mean what's really interesting there is
it is in fact fulfilling its remit as a
medium rather than simply serving from
the old information model as a carrier
it's not just a carrier content so we
have some folks ready to give some
questions so um I direct this to Patty
ziman um
doesn't this make you think a little bit
back to the days of early video art and
uh in terms of breaking the medium and
creating Civic space uh and also in
terms of installation and what happened
there I think it really uh is not a new
paradigm but it's actually just smaller
screens different uh configurations if
that work maybe speak to that a little
sure I'd be happy to in fact I have a
note about this um yeah I have a whole
index card on that so so thanks for that
question um you know I I think when you
know because I'm a historian like bill
um whenever I heard hear the word new uh
I go for my gun right because new always
carries with it uh not just one history
but many many histories right and I
think as we're looking at new
documentary forms or the new Arts of
documentary uh I'm really noticing a lot
of both amnesia and anesthesia right
both Amnesia about these histories uh
video art I absolutely agree I do not
think we would have New Media
interactive documentary without uh video
art and I'm from upstate New York where
we had the first video art exhibitions
in the United States at Syracuse
University and at the Ithaca Video
Festival so I you I live in the middle
of that of that history absolutely I
would even go back and say fluxus and
conceptual ual art from the 60s uh I
think is really percolating there as
kind of grandfathers and grandmothers um
surrealist interventions I'm thinking
about uh you know things like Eric
sati's on TR I'm thinking about uh
George onai and the music for ballet
mque so you know I think these
genealogies are shifting right that
we're no longer looking at just this
forward March of film but we're now
looking at New Media as it has um um
multiple uh tributaries of of History
coming in so I really thank you for the
video art uh I do think in the United
States video art was really important in
this notion of the multiplication of
screens and the multiplication of places
and the multiplication of people right
like moving away from the
unitary screen so I I couldn't agree G
more yes that was even nonlinear work
I'm just putting it on the way yeah and
you know I have to give a shout out to
the experimental
television uh Center experimental TV
Center in iggo New York which shuttered
its doors after 40 years which was a
place that was really an epicenter for
technological innovation video art and
screens the um a lot of the synthesizer
were invented there and it shuttered its
doors because the people who ran it are
wanting to retire but one thing that
they mentioned uh at a forum we did last
year was there is no need for it anymore
with um a computer technology right so
when you used to have to go to the
experimental TV Center to work with
synthesizers and and do all this so it
is sort of a moment of a garden that
flowered and now is transformed into
many many Gardens you might think of
about it as a the forms actually have
already have always been germinating all
this time but the platform has changed
and thereby the access to these forms
have changed and the interest has
changed changed the forms as well and it
has changed the forms I mean if you look
at the you know the work that's coming
out of the nfb you know it it reminds me
of some of the early you know
experimental work that I you know engage
saw in the 80s and program the early 90s
but it wasn't getting the hits you know
and and it and and wasn't as polished
you know but so it's it's a new platform
as well there's something to be said
about we we don't know what's in our
bloodstream you know and it it gets
executed Illustrated in some way I mean
I work for an organization that also has
been producing oour animation for 70
years so we work you know side by side
with people doing a we have two animated
shorts nominated for Oscars this year
that is it's not unusual for us to
incorporate animation in documentary
it's just you know given when it's
appropriate so mixing media has just
been part of the culture and we never
saw it that way it was only executed in
that way animation in a documentary now
it's perhaps we're thinking about um uh
you know a more fluid approach with
interactive and it just it comes
naturally maybe without us realizing it
but I do think I think that that that's
the notion of what what it means when
you think about the internet as as
artist material you know and and how
that changes I mean remembering
obviously that there is this lineage and
it was there was actually as part of
documentary fortnite at um mom um Lauren
Cornell from uh ryome gave a talk about
sort of documentary and and um digital
art sort of coming together and someone
in the audience actually did make a
point about the fact that we we sort of
started quite late in terms of our
presentations and that there was
actually this whole history which was
very relevant to the conversation that
we we hadn't been able to touch on
because because of the time constraints
but I I do think there was a bit of
collective Amnesia I mean especially in
terms of the sort of New Media do
doumentary practitioners today about and
it comes back to the shush as well like
this is shushing in and we don't even
know what is what it you know what that
tributary
is one sort of overriding impression one
has thinking about the discourse that
you've engaged in today is that uh or at
least that I have is an old statement my
mother used to make as she became more
and more impatient with certain sort of
commercial development she said what's
wrong with the United States is there
are too many flavors of ice cream and I
think I I have the feeling there are too
many flavors of choice here there that
is to say you've described such a
circumstance of emerging chaos that two
Central questions emerge that I hope
everyone would would address the first
is that this chaos causes what we might
call a kind of cognitive confusion or a
or a or or some of you have used the
term Amnesia uh one from a from a
historical or intellectual standpoint
this new chaos creat creates the problem
that um avanguard movements which
several of you have been just alluding
to uh people who think of the artists
who think of themselves as as subversive
in some way or as as as as driving new
new possibilities are merging with
people who are completely the opposite
of avanguard who are ordinary uh uh uh
uh computer not ordinary but are
different kinds of ordinary people in
the society who use computers to make
mashups or to make their own
own home movies and their inclination
their impulse is quite the it's not the
same sort of ideologically uh
self-conscious move that an avanguard
artist May what what an irony that these
two incredibly diverse populations one
almost a if not a mass population a very
populous group uh in somehow having
having a convergence with with an
avanguard that incredibly complicates
the situation even even just in terms of
making sense of the kinds of projects
that that are emerging
so that's a sort of General comment
about the kind of confusion I think
you've described but the questions I
have are twofold one we this issue has
come up and it's embedded in what I've
just been saying how do you deal with
the broad question of what we called in
our recent conference here the
instability of platforms William
mentioned this early in your discourse
what does a uh uh uh an aspiring young
documentarian of all even a diverse one
who has some competence across different
media platforms do in facing not only
the enormous number of choices that are
available to her but also beyond that
the deep deep question of whether or not
the platforms chosen will be around in
five years what do what do we do with
leaving leaving aside what that means
for archivists and Librarians and and
and people who want to sort of keep a
history of thing what do we do about the
fact that we seem to be in a moment in
which platforms are so totally
unstable um you're putting out a a a
question um that describes a lot of
confusion but actually the answer is
very simple and it's been this the same
answer from the beginning you start with
your story and what's the only
difference is that it's it it gets
confusing if you start if you try to fit
the the the round peg in a square hole
if you're thinking about these kinds of
new forms uh and and and and engaging
with them in old ways in in ways that
are passive and and they're all the
they're so different and they have to be
um categorized in a certain way but if
you have a
story and you want to tell the story if
you if you flip the script on the on the
filmmaker or the the Storyteller these
are options to tell the story
simultaneously all at once and it's the
same story it's it's it's the story
world that they're building so I would
say you know that you know for for
filmmakers who are growing up and and
and wanting to to tell stories you don't
have to choose one or the other start
with your story what is it that you want
to tell and then think about how you
could communicate it given these
different platforms U and remember that
there these platforms are not
necessarily going to be monetized in the
ways that they used to but you might
actually expand your reach uh for the
the conversation you want to have uh the
message you want to give the world that
you want to paint um it it might EXP
expand that that's sort of the pay up
that's the um that that's that's what
you get out of out of these new forms
that are not yet monetized and who knows
if they might not be down the line well
one one response to that I I one way to
respond to what you've said is to say
that's a very conservative response I
mean I like it very much because what it
says is forget about this Cornucopia of
choices you have make rational much much
more concise and narrow selections
depending on what you want to say and uh
depending on your vision of experience
that you that that all that all the
options need not be or are inappropriate
for particular kinds of stories but it
seems to me that there are much uh
bigger issues involved having to do with
I'm not even talking about monetizing
things but you want your material to
last uh and you put it on one system and
it's gone I mean I I'm wondering about
that and even about people who want to
fund projects that go on platforms that
have not established a life a life sty a
life
trajectory I'd like to take this on so
uh get
ready um okay I I I think this it's
interesting to me like when you use the
words chaos and instability because as
somebody who's a been spent a long time
working in critical historiography
postcolonial and post structuralist
theorists um are constantly asking for
instability and for looking at chaos I
mean if we look at Raj guha for example
Indian historiographer he argues uh why
is it we cannot discuss the ghosts that
don't exist the specters who are in
history right so chaos and instability I
think are really uh
important um because I think that the
work that we're looking at now across
all these different
forms actually we're in the realm that
art historians call the Post object so I
don't think we're really looking anymore
in the same way or thinking the same way
about we are going to preserve this you
know this film or this particular
interface or this algorithm or this I
think that in the realm of the post
object where the performative and the
iterative and precisely the instability
and the chaos are part of the build of
the work right it's almost like the the
code or the algorithm of the work that
we're shifting into a different set of
concerns right maybe all that matters is
that we can describe what Sam green did
right but we may never have a
documentation of what that's like
because each project I mean many of the
projects that I'm interested in change
wherever they're shown change in
particular locations and it's
exactly this chaos and instability that
is the break with with the past um and
then I'm going to just provide something
very Zen um I think sometimes in Western
cultures we want
everything to be
saved but every everything is always
deteriorating and as historians we know
this I mean I've spent my whole career
looking at work that's not saved in
archives right and it's just never there
so you're endlessly dealing with absence
so instead
of for a la of a better word being
hysterical about absence we have to
embrace the absence and embrace the
deterioration because we don't really
want anything to stay the same if we
adopt a postcolonial
historiography right and this means
realizing everything will become a
ghostly Spectre and I know that sounds
really theoretical but I really believe
it um and I want to just give a larger
more concrete example which is engaged
media in Indonesia which is a kind of um
incredible project for the Asia Pacific
for environmental and human rights um
technologists artists NOS Gathering
Together user uploaded but it's citizen
journalism and it's Nos and its
activists and human rights groups um now
this emerged out of uh reformasi
movements in the late 90s to create a
civil society in Indonesia now for them
uh it exists online but many communities
they work in in Indonesia or in the Asia
Pacific uh don't have electricity so the
only way to show this work where there's
no bandwidth and there's no internet
connection is to put it on USB stick and
bring a generator into Papa where
there's it's a big conflict zone now but
I would wager if you talk to people who
are working with engaged media the issue
is not to save those images but actually
to create Civil Society for debate for
engagement for public gatherings in
Indonesia and rebuild that country and
that national identity after
uh um suaro so I think sometimes we have
to really remember that documentary is
about being urgent it's about
communicating with others about that
which matters which are really life or
death issues and they're different
around the world but I I would just say
does it matter for engaged media to have
this all saved or is there maybe a goal
of of really working to for for other
other issues so you know I'm kind of
polemical and I apologize I hope you'll
be gracious to me but you raised a great
question that was that was an exciting
answer and I certainly agree with a lot
of what you've said but docum I feel
like I mean documentaries to me you know
I've always been really nervous of um I
mean because I I used to work in uh in
at Channel 4 in the UK and commissioning
and um I was always really nervous uh
about people talking about sort of
documentary you know with a sort of a
wide brush because the kind of films I
was looking at then it was film you know
films were of a certain length but they
were so different and they were doing
such different things and I think in
this space now I mean I I agree you know
I definitely embrace the instability I I
that's the thing about it right now that
I think is so exciting um but I I'm
really nervous about I like every
project is really different and every
project has different goals and you know
not all documentaries need to change the
world I I think that projects do
different things for different people
and sometimes need to reach lots and
lots of people and sometimes they need
to reach just a very small handful of
people but do something in a very
particular way and I so for me now what
I think is you know really interesting
about this space is is um you know how
just knowing what your digital pallet is
that's how I always think about it like
if you don't know what your options are
like so for example one of the things
that really concerns me is a lot of
filmmakers or makers or creators in the
space are incredibly disconnected from
the politics of the internet um and they
don't really think about about open
source code or net neutrality or any of
these issues which are really going to
affect all these conversations we're
having in this room right now I mean if
they change the way the internet works
then all these conversations we're
having are going to change and post
object or pre- object or I mean we're
not going to be able to do the same
kinds of work so you know I think that
kind of the politics of the code and the
politics of the technology is also
really really important knowing what our
digital palet is and protecting the bits
of that pallette that we you know that
which for me is a free and open internet
is really really key
I I I think I'm just going to Echo some
of what's been said I I think you know
while film and video are incredibly
stable platform or we think of them as
an incredibly stable platform you know
there are tens of thousands of
independent documentaries that have
vanished and nobody seems to care you
know they they could be physically
preserved but they aren't and uh so
they're completely inaccessible or gone
uh despite the fact they're you know
they're fixed in a medium that we kind
of understand so in some ways
interactive documentaries are going to
share the same fate that that those
documentaries already have um but
there's no question that there's been
very very little discussion about the
lifespan of of interactive documentaries
I think in some ways it's even um an
assumption that they'll just date so
quickly uh you know projects we did uh
five years ago look dated to us in a way
that you know a classic documentary film
doesn't and so there's almost this you
know I'd be happy if nobody's looking at
it six years from now um but I I think
it's partly because of who's been
involved and it it again it speaks to
that I'm I'm not um suggesting that only
documentary filmmakers should occupy
this space not at all but I think it's
often been people who've been doing the
hard labor of building interactive sites
have usually been doing they pay their
rent by doing corporate work that isn't
meant to last so they don't have an
archival mentality that there's some
user that needs to see this corporate
video corporate interactive project
seven years from now it's it's nobody
cares really um but I do feel that
interactive is is already an interactive
documentary sensibility is already
having um I think a good influence on
the creativity of linear documentaries
because there's simply so many stories
that were never told in the linear form
um you know what a new form maybe does
is allow us to look at the old form
that's pretty obvious thing to say look
at the old form um in a way we haven't
before and so you know in a country like
Canada and most countries in the world
an hourlong documentary it's on
television is actually 43 minutes you
know a TV hour and so magically most of
the proposals we receiv received in the
last 20 years were 43 minute ideas um
you know it's like every novel had to be
253 Pages um so now they you know ideas
were turned down your story is too thin
it won't fill 43 minutes or a feature
length it's not it's not strong enough
to sustain that well now it doesn't
matter if it's 4 minutes minutes it can
work uh either as a short film online
for a big audience or as an interactive
piece so I think that's liberating but I
think there are really believe there is
a sensibility and interactive
documentary which is somewhat different
and maybe less journalistic uh to some
extent I think it's drawing in a more
artistic approach something there's
something about the peripheral vision
the marginal Vision that is that uh you
know if we if we said we were going to
make a film about it it would seem
trivial but when it's done as part of an
art installation there's something human
and personal about it and people people
don't turn up their noses I guess it's a
the challenge to filmmakers documentary
filmmakers is to have a kind of
preconceptual moment and rather than say
I have an idea to make a film it's just
I have an idea and let's see what the
right form is for that you know an EXC
an excellent example is uh this piece
called question Bridge uh that was
subject of conversation earlier today
and I and I think about this this pie
pie in relation to another film that we
showed at Sundance called love which is
was an
autobiographical um uh story about and
these these these these two pieces are
stories about black
men uh love is a is a specific story
it's beautifully told story this
narrative film about a young boy coming
of age uh falling around his um his
uncle who just got out of the um out of
prison but wanting you know to establish
a legit business uh it is a fantastic
film and the and the story that that
filmmaker wanted to tell was that
specific story in the in the in the in
the in the case of question Bridge uh
the the filmmakers the artists their
story wanted they what they wanted to do
was to have black men defi tell their
own story uh established through
conversation not so much conversation
but just to tell their own story so they
had this digital digital you a digital
platform available to them so so that
what was really important and it's
always important to have you know a
record but I think what's what was the
most important for for those makers was
to to create a conversation amongst
black men using new digital technology
in a way that has never been possible
before because the digital technology
enabled these men to speak from a safe
space and uh in a very focused way and
and and the payoff was so enormous I
can't tell you uh how this thing played
at Sundance it it play to all kinds of
races and all kinds of Crees and colors
and and having access to a conversation
between black men that just that really
just wouldn't be possible outside of the
safe safe space that this digital
technology provided so you can call that
um you know you can call that you can
have and you can have anxieties about
you know preserving this work and
certainly I respect that you know from
the academy but boy did it ever uh
achieve the goal of the makers and boy
did it ever contribute to American
society by opening up a conversation
that was just never possible
before it's actually a perfect segue to
my question you touched upon it actually
but I'll ask it anyway so throughout
this talk of um you know just it seems
as though we might all agree that the
form of the documentary if anything has
transitioned to uh open up some
opportunities instead of just telling a
story and you know having that story
exist in in its form and perhaps a
dialogue would exist after that but that
would be it instead of that um we have
an opportunity here with with these new
forms of technology to to sort of
initiate a Continuum uh to start with an
idea perhaps and start with a call to
action perhaps but importantly uh keep
people engaged in this story um or at
least I see that opportunity so that the
you know the story can just evolve and
and grow
organically um so if if you agree with
that notion would you also agree that um
the role of the creator has has also
evolved to Encompass not just coming up
with an idea or even um presenting a
call to action um for the general public
to respond to but also to to
equip uh the general public or at least
their target audience uh with with the
tools to empower them to respond back
and to actually Eng to empower them to
engage in the story to create part of
the media um so for example similar to
what you just described um you know I
see the Artist as as coming up with a
framework to say all right I want these
these stories to Bubble Up on their own
and and to me that's that's an important
shift um I guess I'm not directing it to
anyone in particular but if anyone like
to respond to that I'd love to respond
because ien to sh
talk actually was was thinking um you
know what is a significant shift we're
seeing across all these forms and it is
from the idea of an individual director
with a kind of logo Centric point of
view or maybe a you know political point
of view or a whatever give voice to the
voic less make an image of the image
image list right to like I I call it the
uh you know the documentary of
reparation right repair something and I
think what we're moving towards at least
in the projects I'm interested in and
again you know I'm seeing this all over
the world and I want us to be really
careful that we just don't Center
everything in countries of the global
North I think we're shifting from this
idea of the director of the reparation
to the convenor and designer of the
experience that creates conversations
and convenings I think I think question
Bridge highrise I mean so many of these
projects have this share this um and
this idea
becomes alator right it becomes
unpredictable and the unpredictability
of this becomes that which
Motors uh the project I think we're
shifting from the idea of a story to the
idea of stories you know Salon rushi
calls it the Sea of Stories not the drip
of a story but the Sea of Stories and he
says in harun and the Sea of Stories
we're in the boat we take our cup and we
dip it into the Sea of Stories and I
think that that's a great theoretical
model for thinking of these user
generated projects uh I said earlier in
the day I think we're moving from
Shakespearean generic models to what I
would call again my old 70s feminist
erupt so pardon me to what I would call
the shaherazad model right of multiple
stories I think we're moving from one
kind of sense of temporality to multiple
temporalities we're maybe moving a
little bit from time to different
spatializations I think high-rise to me
emblematized that right it's it's a
space so I mean where are we is we're
rethinking structures and we're thinking
of structures in ways that are about
thinking of
ways of creating conviviality I I think
these hard hitting in-your-face projects
are still a space for them and but I I
think in some parts of the world to make
a hard in-your-face work is going to put
you in jail or you lose your life uh and
that sometimes creating spaces for
conviviality uh I'll give you the
example in Indonesia or Malaysia or
parts of India um Nigeria have become
really important um they are a mode of
survival um I think we're seeing these
projects migrate I I don't like this
term trans media because transnational
corporations use it so I try to use the
term migratory because it's kind of
environmental right you know so you know
do you know what I mean it's like we're
migrating and so I really thank you for
that that that question because I think
it gets to um the ethical heart of uh
what so many of these projects people
have described um you know I think we're
not looking at Big movements as much
anymore as we're looking at safe spaces
small spaces hijacked spaces occupied
spaces but there are smaller spaces uh
there are micropia if if you will so
thanks but there is there just to be the
bring it back to praic funding and and
sustainability for whoever the creators
are are um there are real issues around
that because you know the one thing we
do know it's very hard to get any kind
of documentary made um we all know that
but with a with a linear documentary you
pretty much know how much it's going to
cost and you you you can pretty much
time it out I mean there's all sorts of
things that might come up as you make
your film but you know what the
development period looks like you know
what the production period looks like
you pretty much know how long you're
going to be in the edit and you know
what the distribution looks like after
that with these projects that's not the
case at all and so with 18 days in Egypt
which is exactly what you just described
um you know it's incredibly exciting for
and yasman but they're also like
oh my God like what are we in you know
what do we get ourselves into because
when does it end because there is no end
it was called 18 days in Egypt but they
realized you know the story of Egypt
didn't end on the last day of the
Revolution um and so you know this this
project is continuing and also they
realized there was a huge digital access
issue they that a lot of the things they
expected to happen didn't happen because
you know one of the things I always say
when people say oh there'll be user
generated content I'm like if you're
lucky um the lot you know that the best
problem to have is how to moderate that
content um generally you don't even get
any content so so one of the issues they
had is um having to actually have
fellows on the ground in Egypt you know
taking sort of tablets and phones around
to actually collect these stories um and
I mean this this is all incredibly
exciting if you talk to either one of
them they will you know tell you lots of
stories about how they've really changed
about they've changed the way they think
about them their roles as as
storytellers uh jiger calls himself a I
don't know what he calls himself now but
he has a very and he comes from an
interesting space as well because he
used to work in multimedia journalism so
he's always felt quite comfortable I
think sort of dancing Between Worlds um
but I think it has been quite
challenging for them and I think you
know looking ahead um there there's
going to be a lot of really difficult
decisions to make um and I think a lot
of this also comes back to you know do
um having good Partnerships on board so
that you do actually have a longterm
plan and maybe there is an extra
strategy for you as the Creator if
necessary um because I you know I still
I I always talk about this but I do
always think about um people you know
paying their rent and maybe being able
to retire one day I think it's really
important yeah um thank you both for uh
tremendous responses um and if I could
just follow up quickly um you touched
upon a key point which inspired the
question I mean I see that there are
different places in the world and they
have different capabilities it's one
thing to look at you know the latest
iPad that's coming out and think of all
the exciting ways that we can use it
that's important that's great someone's
got to do that someone also has to bring
these tools to people who you know have
a hard time finding water or whatever
their story still needs to be told and
they need to engage even if it's within
their local
community um and so I guess just to
reiterate I would I would see the role
of this Creator as sort of this
amalgamation of of um the technologist
whose responsibility is to you know if
they're applying for a grant or
something they they might scope out the
work and say I'm I'm building this tool
and this is is these are the features
that it's going to have perhaps the
documentary maker uh has to start doing
or maybe not has to but has an
opportunity to to do something like that
to say you know I I actually just want
to empower these people in a unique way
and um and this is the scope of the
project that I that I intend to deliver
would you ever see something like that
floating or well I mean what you know
one of the things that makes me
incredibly nervous in uh in applications
is is when people talk about giving
voice to the voiceless because I think
that's the most patronizing uh you know
I mean it's it's it's a it's a reflex
phrase that people use but you know I
think looking at Technologies now going
back to that idea of the digital pallet
you know there there people have
Technologies everyone has some kind of
Technology um yeah true and and there
are ways of accessing them so I mean I
you know I absolutely agree and I do
always think about appropriate
Technologies and and the way that we're
creating these stories but but I I think
that one actually what what what has
been amazing about this new way of
creating stories and and creating
stories with people is actually really
challenging that idea of like the the
Savior filmmaker giving voice to the
voiceless um I think that's really
really important I totally agree and I
just want to raise like another point
and this is sort of a Cassandra Point uh
which is um you know I've been in a lot
of forums in the last couple of years
where people are so excited about user
generated upload content um and I I
speak as someone who's lived a lot in
Southeast Asia Okay so so you hear this
you know and what I've heard in
Southeast Asia and in India is uh user
generated content Amer they call it
American generated content right and
I've heard that everywhere I've been in
the global South so and you know I think
we have to realize that Technologies
networks and
nodes are not the same around the globe
and I don't want to fall back into old
90s talk about dig digital divides
because I mean we have places that are
leapfrogged right Singapore is more
technologically sophisticated than the
United States but we have you know
governments that can shut down different
nodes at will uh we don't have YouTube
in China but we have a vital underground
documentary movement in the D Cinema and
I I want to just raise this issue and
it's an ethical issue which is right now
an image made is an image that will
circulate across many Networks across
many nodes across many countries and it
is an image that will be remixed beyond
recognition and I think you brought that
up this morning it will be remixed
beyond recognition so there becomes a
question of what are the ethics of ugc
when we're thinking that um works are
being maybe made on cell phones and
places where if your image is on the
internet the security forces are going
to crowdsource you and put you in jail
we saw this in Iran uh we've seen it in
Burma we've seen it in India uh we've
seen it in Indonesia and we've seen it
in parts of West West Africa right so
what do we do with this and I think
there's a lot of work being done by
engaged media by tactical technology
Collective by witness to and I've been
working on a project with Sam Gregory
from witness on circulatory media and
ethics so if we say an image made and an
image uploaded is going to be
recirculated I think we have to go back
to Human Rights discourse that
emphasizes the Dignity of the subject
and now subjects and uploaders need to
realize that the glories of uh you know
having all these cameras can also
be
um the difficulties of Security
Forces uh of getting you and putting you
in jail or could be the the difficulties
of maybe you're not going to get that
scholarship to the university because
you were in protest movement or you said
something so you know I I just find I
have to think a lot to refocus on the
Dignity of the subjects in a circulatory
universe is it always important to have
an image of everything is it always
important to have a face so for example
witness and engaged media are working I
think they're going to roll this out
soon with a cell phone app that if
you're in a conflict area it'll blur
faces right so it'll document abuse but
it will blur faces this has been really
very very important um you know in
Indonesia and in the Middle East and in
North North Africa because we've seen
what security forces uh uh do here so I
I I don't mean to be the person who
throws the the water on the party but um
I think sometimes we have to still think
about those old ideas from documentary
which is about we in the documentary
world are telling stories about other
people and I always think we have to
always Center ourselves by not being
centered on ourselves we have to think
about the subjects some people are in
Conflict zones some are in places where
they don't have good
water so we have two more questions and
about eight more minutes so if I could
ask both of you to give your questions
and then we can take them on as a
pool first of all for anyone interested
s Greg tees a CL January class
scho I don't think
that
sorry I'll say this quickly since we're
running out of time um Sam Gregory
teaches a class at the Kennedy School in
January it's an open enrollment class
for cross registration for anyone who's
here who's interested and he's um from
The Witness Program so and I took his
class this January as part of the car
center for human rights policy and it
was great so I recommend it um but my
question is switching back to the
question of money um and you brought up
a very important point about um new
revenue streams or or being creative
with our revenue streams and I wanted to
point out that um social Enterprise and
social entrepreneurship are the big
buzzwords these days around here um and
then we also have social change media
and it seems that never the two shall
meet uh at least not around here um um
I'm taking a class in a Harvard Business
School Harvard County school class on
social entrepr entrepreneurship right
now and all the case studies are on
things like healthc care zip car uh micr
Credit Finance uh and there's nothing in
there about media and so it really got
me thinking like um are there any cases
out there where we can show um tried and
and tried tried well and failed or tried
well and succeeded um where we can look
to um these new tools of doing good by
doing well by doing good now we know
that in in this type of work we do a lot
of good but we don't always do well
we're not always making enough money to
pay the bills so um I really wanted to
go back to that question if you don't
mind and see if any of you are willing
to talk about this sort of um meeting of
these two spheres and seeing um if you
know of anything where this engagement
is happening or if this is a place where
we need to do more work and if so what
do you think I I well I mean sorry just
to LEAP in I think there's lots and lots
of amazing examples of exactly that I
mean I don't know if necessarily the
media makers would consider themselves
social entrepreneurs some of them might
Jer certainly would he's got a really
interesting I think he's like a social
media entrepreneur or media entrepreneur
but um but there's I think there's lots
and lots of examples of that kind of
work being done through media in really
powerful ways I mean Paco and Pamela
with um with a with aanin and and and
more recently with granito have done
some incredible work and I mean granito
really has affected real you know real
world change um in Guatemala and they're
creating an a a sort of a memory what's
it called the memory every memory matter
every memory matters uh you know to
collect stories uh with the forensic
teams in Guatemala um I mean this you
know I think that that's actually one of
the the really interesting and really
urgent things that is happening in media
I think I think maybe we are a little
bit nervous about calling ourselves
anything with the word entrepreneur in
it um I don't know why that is but I
think maybe I think I think that work's
happening we just don't call it that and
maybe we don't get recognized for that
as a
result
anybody well is it is it compiled
somewhere I mean it's important that
someone who like myself is trying to go
out there and make the media happen and
and you know on Bare Bones in the
beginning and then you know trying to
raise the money and pull it together and
and it's really good to have these these
uh examples to pull from and I'm
wondering if that seems like a good
project if it hasn't already been done
to pull them together as a body of work
has anybody got anything else um I have
an example and it's from Malaysia um and
uh you know I think sometimes we focus
so much on media that we forget that
larger social political
historical um
configurations often have lacks that
media can meet so I'll give you this
concrete example which is the website
Malaysia Kenny it's the
oppositional uh citizen journalism News
website in Malaysia it's um started
because because as you probably know
Malaysia has a multimedia Corridor where
it is doing quick leapfrogging
development with new technologies but
Malaysia has a lot of film censorship
and television censorship for a variety
of reasons I mean they would call it
regulation here in America we'd call it
censorship but there's an opposition
movement in Malaysia and so what did
they do the Malaysians never regulated
the internet because that would stop
transnational companies like Microsoft
and digital developers from coming into
the multimedia Corridor so the internet
had an opening so Malaysia Kenny became
uh this site of Citizen
journalists telling stories of the
opposition movement in Malaysia not
regulated not censored because to do
that would be bad for business films you
know narrative films documentaries
censored so m AIA Kenny is now one of
the most economically
successful internet projects in all of
Southeast Asia right who would have
thought it so but again is it because
it's an online citizen journalist
project no it's because it worked the
cracks right and fulfilled a need right
a need for a kind of Civil Society
public discourse um you know around
these economic development issues and
and political issues and I think it's a
really exciting example in fact I was at
a a journalist conference in Singapore
where every major Daily Newspaper all
over Asia was asking Malaysia Kenny how
they could have citizen journalism for
their big commercial Enterprises so uh
you know just one example but the
example I think requires not thinking
about media that can be monetized but
thinking about uh thinking about where
in Social political historical
configurations is there a crack is there
a need is there an
urgency great I think we have to wind it
down here on this very optimistic note
and let me just give a plug to the Civic
media folks here uh because that's a
place where a lot of these conversations
also occur about alternate forms of both
gathering information giving it form
getting it out to publs uh that work
terrifically in all sorts of cultural
spaces uh and they have very regular
events so just keep an eyee on the
website for the center for civic media
because that's that's their core work I
want to thank our panel um it was a
terrific conversation thanks very
much